oh i didn't even know that was possible
so we have to know where to los angeles
for the biggest youtuber ping pong
tournament hosted by era let's go 12
creators battling for 120 000 and during
their matches we were giving them
different distractions check out the
full tournament on eric's youtube
channel but before the event started we
challenged the creators to do some quick
shots i think they're all inside waiting
for us yeah let's go check it out i'm
gonna hit the ping pong ball from behind
the back ah behind the back okay
all right i've never done this in my
life watch this though
oh
good touch for it yeah thank you thank
you so much
the challenge is
that okay one bounce edge one bounce
edge and one back okay i'm trying to
beat you no you don't have to beat me
you can do a challenge yeah okay
whoa
it's quite hard it's quite hard yeah i
can bounce it on one side
oh man
yes
and there we have it yay
that only took like one minute that was
impressive that was impressive
between the leg shots
okay yeah
you see i haven't practiced that one but
i'll give it a go through the
legs okay
here we go
oh nice
but seriously i was impressed you got
four and a half me too honestly i had no
idea i would actually do that but you
killed it you made that look easy
i missed one so you have to do it with
two balls yeah you're gonna have to do
better
i need like the whole freaking set i
every ball here please thank you oh i
only have two
i think you're about 11 tries
thank you thank you
all right so you know the challenge
i'm scared
i thought around the world was kind of
like when you just hit it and then we
run around like the you're telling me we
have to spin it and yeah around the neck
yeah yeah no i got this i'm sweating our
tits right now
you two can have a battle who gets the
best around the night show okay
yeah
oh that was closed okay all right i'm
getting it now you got it you got it
okay no i'm not
oh that was close he's going so far
i feel like it was like semi-decent yeah
you think you can do better than alex
yeah
[Applause]
i'm trying to curb it
in the camera
and the camera
lucky it was lucky okay who's gonna try
though
thank you it's an aim for effort yeah
all right so the idea is to smash this
[Music]
not first try
so yeah that's how you do it
yeah
if you do it in one i'll be really
embarrassed
okay make him look bad
that was bigger than you
champion i think i think pongfinity has
a new member i'll just you know i'll
leave my right check me out next week
guys
mama made it
you need to go further
oh no it's turning into a competition
like
i'm on makeup
oh no
okay
okay
i'm nervous
okay one more and then we're even
it was like this
okay one serve we see one serve
okay
okay
okay can i try those after yeah you can
you can yeah i have no clue
you just need one walk in return
thanks
that was
good you did really well
the idea is to play with three balls at
the same time or three yeah you think
you can manage i think maybe we did two
number three so and i'm only going to
show you the example and then yeah
just a really light hit try to get the
rhythm
[Applause]
hey i think you're ready for the third
one
yeah
good job
[Applause]
yeah yeah that's right
that was amazing and it's not magic this
is not one of his no
no anything although maybe in the future
we'll do something like that
otto's best serves okay
[Music]
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
i was trying i actually was trying and i
couldn't do it
[Music]
oh wait you're gonna go good job bro
comment below who you think did the best
and big thanks to arak for hosting his
tournament inviting us it was so much
fun go and check out his channel and
subscribe there as well until next time